con bastante tranquilidad y filas fuera
de alguno de los colegios electorales en
los distritos más poblados transcurren
la primera de las dos jornadas en la que
aproximadamente 15 millones de chilenos
están llamados a elegir a las 155
personas encargadas de escribir una
nueva constitución que sepulte para
siempre la constitución de 1980 heredada
de la dictadura de augusto pinochet se
tratan de las elecciones especialmente
complejas donde además de candidatos
constituyentes se elegirán a alcaldes
concejales y gobernadores por primera
vez en un intento de descentralizar el
país son en total más de 16.000 los
candidatos que se presentan a estas
elecciones para optar a 2006 más de 2700
cargos hemos visto a primera hora de la
mañana la participación de muchos
adultos mayores se espera que este rango
etario tenga una mayor participación que
en el plebiscito anterior puesto que
muchos de ellos ya se encuentran
completamente vacunados hay mucha
incertidumbre tanto sobre la
participación en estas elecciones
históricas de esta convención
constituyente que será paritaria por
primera vez en el mundo y que contará
con candidatos indígenas por primera vez
en chile tanto como sobre la composición
de esa convención constituyente que
decidirá
el futuro del chile en las próximas
décadas